[Music]
spread their wings are attempting to fly
hopefully not becoming the failures we
all expect them to be oh my oh you are
so pumped for a pitch-perfect three is
in theaters around Christmas time and
the trailer was actually just released
and it shows up that the Barden Bellas
are actually going their separate ways
after graduation but we would not have a
movie Nancy if the ladies weren't
getting back together for another
acapella competition and Remy Wilson
just told our Carly Steele all about it
my name is fat Amy Winehouse so let's
get crackin
[Music]
we'll see how the fans enjoy it but it's
very different get ready for a very
different with me
you have to say this weekend the stars
appeared at VidCon a conference for fans
of online video in the movie the Bellas
reunite for a USO tour of Europe pick on
a big adventure there's a little more
action elements this time around
[Applause]
[Music]
there's so much action castmates teased
rebel about a famous Keanu Reeves
character they had a Jake on set they
call me rebel weak boy like an action
star now Jon week oh my god you know
it's definitely so much action I'm very
all the stars have become close friends
and when pitch perfect three wrapped
they didn't want it to end so emotional
I know because we just get so close I
really feel like I have been in a girl
group like the Spice Girls and like
we've been through the ups and downs and
incredible success we have such a fun
time that when we knew that was our last
day of all filming it together
we were just yeah all the girls are
crying because we don't know we don't
know what the future will be after the
third movie so we'll see
oh yeah I'm already pushing for number
four didn't go ahead and put it out
there because sequels are huge and for
this franchise well huge didn't even
really begin to tell the story listen to
this pitch perfect to a sixty nine
million dollars in its first weekend and
that's actually more than the first
movie ever made in the u.s. period so
impressive I know ready for number four
I'm in
[Music]
you